este grupo de tumbas que está a mis
espaldas es solo una pequeña
demostración de la complejidad de este
cementerio de Body sale en la ciudad de
nayafi también muestra la complejidad de
los conflictos que ha vivido Irak en los
últimos años a mis espaldas solamente
hay dos tumbas de integrantes de las
fuerzas especiales o de las fuerzas
iraquíes y también uno de los milicianos
de una de esas tantas milicias que se
han fortalecido desde la invasión
norteamericana es tan especial la
milicia de sader que tiene gran
presencia y que tuvo un papel muy
importante en la lucha contra la
presencia norteamericana pero también
todas estas milicias luego tuvieron un
papel muy importante en la lucha contra
el estado islámico y cada uno de ellos
era traído a enterrar a este cementerio
donde por más de 1.400 años dos chicas
de Irak traen a los suyos a enterrar y
todo por una razón muy especial
está en la ciudad de nayabs cerca a lo
que es el mausoleo del imán Ali que es
el fundador de esta secta del sismo que
si bien es la segunda en el mundo en
practicantes de su fe es la mayoría en
Irak Así que no importa en qué parte de
este país las personas viven cuando una
persona fallece la traen hasta aquí
primero la llevan al mausoleo allí hacen
la ceremonia y más adelante ya la traen
la traen a enterrar aquí que hace Qué ha
pasado con eso pues han logrado que el
espacio se acabe y muchas de estas
tumbas tengan que estar enterradas unas
sobre la otra de aquí que mostramos esta
magnitud de este cementerio aquí más
adelante van a poderlo ver y esto se ha
hecho mayor con Las Guerras que ha
vivido Irak en los últimos décadas
primero en esta guerra contra Irán en la
década de los 80 donde murieron miles y
miles de personas están Están enterrados
aquí luego tenemos esa guerra la
invasión norteamericana la la protesta y
la pelea contra ellos luego esta guerra
sectarias y así sucesivamente ya en los
últimos años esto se ha ido calmando nos
dicen aquí hay menos personas llegando
pero es que no importa que sean Las
Guerras sino cualquier persona que
fallece en el país chiquita lo traen
hasta aquí y lo entierran en este lugar